今日は
普通ならアメリカにチャレンジしにくい
状況でアメリカのニューヨークにプロ
バスケットボール選手を目指して
渡米した時のお話をさせていただけたらと
思いますそれを今日はイケリアの精神と
いらしていただきますで池田の選手とは
何かと言いますと
直感的と
楽観的を混ぜたような感じですかねでなぜ
アメリカにチャレンジしにくい状況だった
かと言いますと
当時20万円
現金20万円で英語は全く喋れず
アメリカになるつながりのない状況でした
で4年間大学4年まで
バスケットボールをさせていただいたん
ですが
プロに行ったり実業団に行くという実力で
はなかったですなので
普通だったらアメリカになかなか
チャレンジしにくいんじゃないかなと
思いますでそのでもあのとても
バスケットボールが好きだったので
バスケットを辞めたくない
NBAでアメリカのトップインがある
アメリカでバスケットをやってみたいと
思いそれで決心して
答弁をすることにしました
で
渡部の
初日
入国審査があったんですがその時も
英語も全くできない状況でしたので僕当時
の感覚だとあの
笑顔で
イエスイエスと
愛想よくしているとそのマークが入れるの
かと思ったのですがそれが逆に
怪しまれて
別室に連れて行かれるようにというような
形になりましたでそれを後々聞くと
別で23時間ねちょっと取り調べをされた
んですがそれは
普通だったらあまりないことだそうです
まあそれが
都営の人自身を出来事ででまずバスケット
をする環境がなかったので
ニューヨークについてから
知り合った知事にこう神で
WheretheBasketGOジムと
書いた神を持ってニューヨークのハーレム
の地域で
場所を探すとかからスタートしました
あの普通だったらそういう状況から
スタートすることあんまりないと思うん
ですけど当時のインターネットもなくあの
何の情報もなかったのでもう1から
スタートということで場所を探し
で
次アメリカでバスケットするには何が必要
かと思った時にやっぱり
フィジカルの上でですね
体が足りてないと思い
体重を10キロ
増やすトレーニングを行いましたでまた
足りてない何が足りてないかというと
バスケットの技術です
で技術をどうやって学んでいくかというと
ニューヨークはいろんなところで
バスケットしてましてとても
うまい選手をたくさんいたんですよねその
選手たちと一緒に
練習することで
スキルを磨いていきましたでそういった
活動をしていく中で
友人もできたり
自分の名前を打っていったのでバスケット
で小さい大会に
読んでもらえるようになりましたでその
小さい大会でも一所懸命バスケットをして
今度は少しずつ大きい大会に呼んでいくで
も呼ばれるようになりました
で最終的にはそのバスケットの大会で
ニューヨークでねとても有名な大会があり
まして世界的に有名なストリート
バスケットの大会がありましてそこに
たどり着くところまで行きましたそれの
写真を見ていただきたいと思います
こちらになりますであのちょっと僕見え
にくいのでこのポイントでさせてもらえ
ますねこれが
僕ですでこここちらで言うとこれが僕です
ねでここ
右下の写真でいうとこれですで
左下はこれで出ますこの4つの写真なん
ですがこれもすごく
有名な大会で一番左上ちょっと紹介させて
いただこうと思うんですがこれは
ニューヨークのハーレム
街ですね黒人の町の
プロジェクトという建物があるんですよね
多分皆さん聞いたことを
多分ないと思うんですがプロジェクトと
いうのは
低所得者の
団地がたくさんあるんですよねそれの
真ん中にバスケットボールコートがあって
そこで大会
夏の2ヶ月間やってるんですけど
ストリートバスケットはそれの
映像ですねでここで
大会がねよくキャンセルになるんですよね
中止になることがあって日本だったら絶対
にありえないことなんですけどそのここで
試合が中心になるっていうのはこの金利で
その日に発砲があるんですよね
そういうような場所なんですよねで
発砲がある時はさすがに退会はできないの
で中止になるというような今考えるとね
とてもまあ賑やかなあの珍しい環境だった
なと思いますでこれこちらの右上のこの
写真なんですがこれEBCと書いてんです
がこれも
ニューヨークのマンハッタンのハーレムの
中心地にある
ラッカーパークという大きな大会がやって
ましてそこでの
映像になりますでコラッカーパークという
のは
NB選手が来てプレイしたり海外のプロ
選手も来てプレイしますもちろん大学の
トップ選手も来てプレイするしそれはなぜ
人たちがここでプレイするかと言いますと
昔ね
黒人の子供さんたちがね
テレビでNBを見れないんですよねあの
貧しくてでその子供たちのためにアメリカ
のプロセ選手たちが公園に集まって
試合をしようとで生のNBAのクオリティ
を子どもたちに見たりしてあげようとこれ
で
全盛期はもうこの
数百人単位ですねでマンションの上に
みんな登って金網登ってみ
るっていうぐらい
すごくあの
有名な大会でした
はいちょっと待ってくださいね
はいでこういうのは大会出させていただい
て次の目標として
独立プロリーグでマイナーリーグという
ところにチャレンジしたいと思い
チャレンジしましたそれもね
全く何も知らない状況でチャレンジしたの
で
どういうリンクがあってどういうチームが
あってどうやったらチームに入るのかそれ
も全部自分で調べてでトライアウトという
試験があるんですよねその試験に自分で
受けに行きましたで
受ける受けたんですがもちろん
落ちるんですよねで
落ちた時に
自分に聞かせたのが
初めてチャレンジすることだから
うまくいかないお家の方が当たり前だと
思ってたのであのアメリカにいる間
自分の中では30歳って決めてたので30
歳まではチャレンジし続けようとまぁ
トータルで言うともう数十回落ちました
でもチャレンジし続けることで2つの
チームでプレイできるところまで来ました
その一つが当時あったusblという独立
リーグで
チーム名が論外ランドプライムタイムズで
もう一つがedaっていうリーグでハリス
バーグホライディーという地域で
プレイさせてもらいました
でまぁ30歳までこういう活動を続けてた
んですが最終目標のエネルベールプレイし
たいと思いはあったんですがNBAが
たどり着かなくなったみたいですでこの前
に
チャレンジしている中でアメリカで独立し
たり
届かないと思ったのでじゃあ今度は1回
ヨーロッパに行ってみようと思って
アメリカから
僕は日本からアメリカに行きたいですか
今度は1回ヨーロッパでチャレンジしよう
と思ってその間にちょっとフランスに行っ
てフランスのプロリーにチャレンジしてで
もう一つはセルビア
セルビアという国でバスケットを学べる
機会があると
って聞いたのでそこで学びに来ました
自分にできるベストを全てを尽くしたん
ですがやっぱり
nveryはたどり着けなかったです
ですがこのチャレンジこの無謀なね
8年間
誰にも期待もされてなかったしあのー
自分で勝手に行ったら中やけれども
12の後悔もないですねで満足感と
感謝しかないですそれなぜなぜかというと
もしチャレンジしてなかったら
アメリカのね
独立プロリーグであったり
ニューヨークの
世界的に有名な大会に出ることはなかった
と思うんですよね
であと
ニューヨークのハーレムねハーレムで
生活することもここに文化に触れて
生活することもなかったと思うんですよね
でとてもあのスペシャルな経験をさせて
もらったので僕はもうチャレンジして
良かったと思うしもう何の効果もないです
ねその20代という一番体の動くときに
自分の大好きなバスケットボールをこう夢
の国アメリカでねあのチャレンジできたり
というのはもう本当に
満足感ですか
ないです満足だともう感謝しかないですで
この
8年間のチャレンジで僕がいろいろ活動さ
せてもらって一番大切にしてたというか
こう学んだことですねそれは何かというと
やっぱり120%で常に
全力でトライするということですねでなぜ
こういう風な考えになったかというと
バスケット
無効でしてていろんなところでバスケット
してたんですがやっぱり
自分の感覚で一生懸命今日はやる今日は
やらで決めるとやっぱりチャンスを拾うの
にいいチャンスにメールに合わないという
か常にアンテナを張るじゃないですけれど
も
全力でどこでもやってると
チャンスは
取りやすくなる出やすくなると僕は思った
のでそれでやってましたで1つの例が
いろんな一つのタイタンでねたまたま
バスケをしてて練習をしててそれでも
やっぱり勝ちにこだわってハードになって
たら
バスケットとね関係のなさそうなあのおじ
さんがたまたま試合を受けてだから
終わった後にいうのが夏の大きい大会の
オーナーだとで君良かったからうちの練習
に来ないからこれもあの誰に求められてた
わけじゃない練習を適当にやってれば
絶対入れなかったと思うんですけどそこで
やっぱり勝ちにこだわってハードワーク
常にベストを尽くしたからこういう話も
もらえるという経験があったのでこれは
日本に帰ってきてもらうんですけどあの常
にハード型
自分の好きなものですね好きであったり
目標夢それをある程度自分が決めた期間
ですね
自分の決めた期間は
常に全力を尽くすっていうのはアの経験
から
学びました
でもう一つは
簡単に
採用がないと思わない
みんな何でもこう初めてやる時ってうまく
いかないのが
当たり前なんですよねでもそれを
失敗という感覚で取ること自体が
僕はあんまり良くないと思ってて
初めてのことをするからやっぱりあの
うまくいかないやり方わからないからそれ
だけなんですよねでそれが
才能ないわけでもないんですよね
例えばプロ選手にしてもまあいろんな
カテゴリーで結果出してる人は人も
いきなりねその場所に行くことは絶対ない
んですよねやっぱり5年10年ある程度の
期間
努力したからこそ
たどり着くと思っているのでだからうまく
いかない時に
僕は方向
努力の方法っていうんですがそれを
どんどん変えて
チャレンジし続ける自分の決めた期間する
とやっぱりそこでの経験値が塾に今度
プラスになってくると思うんで
例えばそこでうまくいかなかったとしても
次の目標
次の夢であったりそういうところで
花がね
咲く可能性はあるんじゃないかなと思い
ます
で
現在は何をしているかと言いますと現在は
バスケットボールアカデミー
の運営と母校のここで大阪経済大学で
バスケットボールのヘッドコーチをさせて
いただきますなぜ自分がバスケットの
アカデミーをスタートしようかと思ったの
がアメリカに行った最後の3年間
NBAのスキル指導
個人技術を指導する工賃であってそこで3
年間バスケットを習ったんですよねでその
時の
練習メニューが
当時20歳まで僕はバスケットしたんです
が
見たことないやったことない練習メニュー
だったんですよね個人の技を上げるで僕は
それに感動して日本を帰った時にぜひこの
アメリカの
選手たちがやってる個人指導を日本の
小中学生に伝えたいと思い
それが一つの理由ですねバスケットボール
のアカデミーをでもう一つがあの
皆さんもね
テレビとかニュースで聞いたことあると
思うんですが
体罰であったり暴言であったり人格を否定
するような指導が日本はすごく多いんです
よねで強くなればなるほどそういうのも
結構あって
僕もそのよく目にしてきてでも
ボックスの好きじゃないんですよねすごく
そういうのが苦手で
なので僕アメリカに持った時にすごく
いろんなコーチポジティブな声こうハード
ワークとか頑張るとか背中を後押しする
ようなこういうの指導が多かったんですよ
ねなのでそれも日本の子供たちに伝えて
高いスキル指導と
前向きなカケ声で
スポーツを通じて
子供たちが自信を持ってもらえるそれが
何よりも大切なんじゃないかなと思って
そのアカデミーをさせていただいてますで
僕のお酒が大学のヘッドコーチは数年前に
オファーをいただいて
受けさせていただきましたで
当時
ちょうど2部から2部リーグからね2部
リーグに降格した
チームでして
で一部消化法を目指してるチームですで
僕は
来させていただいてすごくいい選手にも
恵まれて奇跡的にね1年で2部優勝一部
昇格のところまで行けましたで今チーム
目標としてはあの全国大会インカレと言わ
れている
文法を目標に頑張ってますそれは今25年
ぐらいですかねいけてないですよねそれは
チームの目標としていけるように
頑張っていますそれと同時に
言うてもこう
勝敗というのはやっぱり先週の能力である
程度決まってどうしようもない部分がある
と思うので僕が一番大切にしてるのは
バスボールの子供たちにね大学生に伝えて
いるんですが今ある自分よりも
少しでもうまくなる努力する
で
チームスポーツを通じて人間的に少しでも
成長してもらえるこれが一番大切なことか
なと思ってるのでそこを
メインに
指導させていただいてますで
もう一つが学生4年っていうのが
学生生活最後4年になるんですよねなので
僕は
やっぱり
プロレベルの戦術を
みんなに学んでもらいたかったり
僕は学んできたアメリカの
スキル指導それをみんなで一生懸命制作し
て
成長してもらえたらなと
と思ってます
まあ
僕の情熱としては今はねあのやっぱり全国
大会まあ関西で
トップ
目指して
将来的には日本でねトップ取れるように今
のこのバスケットボール指導に
情熱持ってさせていただいてますであのー
皆さんにお伝えさせてもらいたいと思うの
がやっぱりまあいろいろ迷って何か躊躇し
てできないこととかあると思うんですが
やっぱりやってみるということは
すごく大切だと思うので
失敗って僕はねあの失敗ないと思ってるん
ですよね
本当やり方がわからないからそのそこで
つまずいているだけなんで
失敗はないと思うのでどんどんどんどん
チャレンジしてあとはその
努力の方法ですかねそれをたくさん書いて
ある
っていうのがやっぱり何事でも大切じゃ
ないかなと思いますであの
みんな
皆さんねあのいろんな考えであったり
いろんな方法いろんなストーリーがあると
思うんですがあの
僕の場合はねこういった形でこういった
状況でアメリカで
チャレンジさせてもらいましたまた一つの
ねあの
意見意見というか感覚としてもし
心のどっかにおいていただけたらなと思い
ます今日はこんな感じでさせていただき
ます今日はありがとうございました
[拍手]